dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers
episode number 500 with dr carol jonah
and on this glorious day we are going to
simulate the kinematics of yarn
and cloth on our computers we will
transition into today's paper
in a moment but for context here
is a wonderful work to show you what we
were able to do in 2012
and we will see how far we have come
since this previous work was about
creating these highly detailed
cloth geometries for digital characters
here you see one of its coolest results
where it shows
how the simulated forces pull the entire
piece of garment
together we start out with dreaming up a
piece of cloth geometry
and this simulator gradually transforms
it into a real world version
of that by subjecting it to real
physical forces
this is a step that we call yarn level
relaxation
a few years ago when i worked at disney
research
i attended to the talk of the oscar
award-winning researcher
steve marchner who presented this paper
and when i saw these results
shock waves went through my body it was
one of my truly formative
hold onto your papers moments that i'll
never forget
now note that to produce these results
one had to wait for hours and hours to
compute
all these interactions so this paper was
published in 2012
and now nearly nine years have passed so
i wonder
how far we have come since well let's
see together
today with this new technique we can
conjure up similar animations
where the pieces of garments tighten
beautiful now let's look under the hood
of the simulator
and well well well
do you see what i see here red dots
so why did i get so excited about a
couple
red dots let's find out together these
red dots
solve a fundamental problem when
simulating the movement of these yarns
the issue is that in the mathematical
description of this problem
there is a stiffness term that does not
behave well
when two of these points slide too close
to each other
interestingly our simulated material
gets infinitely stiff
in these points this is incorrect
behavior and it makes the simulation
unstable not good so
what do we do to alleviate this now we
can use this new technique that detects
these cases
and addresses them by introducing these
additional
red nodes these are used as a stand in
until things stabilize look
we wait until these two points slide off
of each other
and now the distances are large enough
so that the mathematical framework can
regain
its validity and compute the stiffness
term correctly
and look the red dot disappears
and the simulation can continue without
breaking
so if we go back to another piece of
under the hood footage
we now understand why these red dots
come
and go they come when two nodes get too
close to each other
and they disappear as they pass each
other keeping the simulation
intact and with this method we can
simulate this beautiful phenomenon
when we throw a piece of garment on the
sphere
and all kinds of stretching and sliding
takes place
marvelous so what else can this do
oh boy it can even simulate multiple
cloth layers
look at the pocket and the stitching
patterns here beautiful
we can also put a neck tag on this shirt
and start stretching and sharing it
into oblivion pay special attention to
the difference in
how the shirt and the neck tag reacts to
the same forces
we can also stack three tablecloths on
top of
each other and see how they would behave
if we would not simulate friction
and now the same footage with friction
much more realistic and if we look under
the hood
you see that the algorithm is doing a
ton of work
with these red nodes
look the table notes that they had to
insert tens of
thousands of these nodes to keep the
simulation intact
so how long do we have to wait for a
simulation like this
the 2012 paper took several hours so
what about this one well this says that
we need
a few seconds per time step and
typically several time steps correspond
to one frame
so where does this put us well it puts
us in the domain of not
hours per every frame of animation here
but
to minutes and sometimes even seconds
per frame
and not only that but this simulator is
also more robust as it can deal with
these unpleasant cases
where these points get too close to each
other so
i think this was a great testament to
the amazing rate of progress
in computer graphics research what a
time to be alive
this episode has been supported by
weights and biases
in this post they show you how to use
their tool to draw
bounding boxes for object detection and
even more importantly
how to debug them during my phd studies
i trained a ton of neural networks which
were used in our experiments
however over time there was just too
much data
in our repositories and what i am
looking for is not data
but insight and that's exactly how
weights and biases helps you
by organizing your experiments it is
used by more than 200 companies and
research institutions
including open ai toyota research github
and more and get this weights and biases
is free for all
individuals academics and open source
projects
make sure to visit them through wnb.com
papers or just click the link in the
video description
and you can get a free demo today our
thanks to weights and biases
for their long-standing support and for
helping us make better videos for you
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and i see you
next time